le centre pénitentiaire de rennes
derrière cette porte
puis des femmes que nous avons enfermé
le seul en france un abriter que des
femmes entre ses murs
cent quarante ans d'histoire de prison
et d'expérimentation au féminin et des
querelles oui
j'en arrive même aux mains parfois oui
bagarre violence un confort comme dans
les prisons pour hommes les détenus les
femmes qui viennent un présent sont en
général condamné il soit pour avoir tué
leur mari soit pour avoir effectué des
mauvais traitements sur leurs quatre
enfants avoir commis des incendies side
beaucoup plus rarement pour avoir commis
des vols
qualifiés mais à rennes le défi c'est de
tout faire pour préparer la vie après la
prison
cela passe par les occupations des
détenus des activités sportives
diversifiées dans les années 80 par
exemple très important parce que c'est
au niveau plastique comme on bat justine
que cantona des années a fallu si on a
envie de rester le rester femme
et puis ma foi de ce maître denis ou de
rester de rester en forme d'avoir une
bonne musculature activités pour
l'esprit aussi avec des auteurs invités
mais alors là je sais pas comment vous
lisez moi je le vis à petites doses
ah oui mais la réinsertion ça passe
surtout par les liens avec l'extérieur
en 2003 une mesure aujourd'hui répandue
a été expérimentée à rennes il s'agit
des unités de vie familiale des petits
appartements pour accueillir les proches
pendant 6 à 72 heures
c'est toujours en vue éventuellement
d'un projet familial et quels qu'ils
soient il peut être très très éloignées
donc laissez ne serait-ce que reprendre
ou envisager de reprendre des contacts
avec la famille mais la question
cruciale celle en cours service client
restauration des archives en plus des
traditionnels ateliers de couture
rémunérés et cet argent vous sert à quoi
payer les parties civiles n'ont cantine
ou vêtements pour maximiser les chances
de réinsertion la prison de rennes fait
venir des entreprises dans son ensemble
quand je travaille là je ne pense pas
que à la prison jamais vad un peu quoi
la prison de rennes
aujourd'hui c'est environ 200 femmes
incarcérées pour des longues peines cet
établissement réputé comme modèle de
réinsertion est aussi connu pour son
faible taux de récidive
[Musique]